ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show we are here with one of the
greatest Comics Louis CK uh you can go
buy the movie 4th of July with Joe list
on his website right now you can get all
five seasons of Louis on the website you
can also get all of the iconic stand-up
specials in a bundle I think for 25
that's right that's cheap it is right
it's very cheap yeah
I would have I would have you would have
clicked I would have hiked it
yeah uh I think I could have maybe yes
but I think that maybe people would have
bought less of them that's a good point
when I when I raise the prices I sell
less of them that tends to happen
interesting and I think uh over time it
ends up not being more money well you
got to come up with a lie like you got
to come up and say these are going away
but that's the thing with digital
content it never goes away it just sits
there you don't even make it yeah they
just bring it they just clone it and
take it for themselves yeah so you can't
do like the farewell tour which a lot of
people will go you know like Cher's done
it three times I mean I'm doing this
tour I'm on tour now and this tour I
mean I mean I don't have the list but
I'm coming to Milwaukee and Atlanta
these are new shows I pronounce
everything I sold out right but then I'm
doing the Madison Square Garden on
January 28th and that's the big one
that's the big one I'm doing that in uh
we sold 10 000 tickets the first day wow
and then now it's uh it's trickling
because the seats get shittier and
shittier right but at the last email I
sent out I said this could be my last
show oh well that's good yeah right it's
not absolutely not of course not but
it's my last show if you want it to be
the last opportunity to ever see me on
stage he's dying it's gonna be like the
Beatles at Shea Stadium yeah he's dying
stage four I'm just that's my last show
the last show yeah
do you ever think of of it when you do
the garden it's going to be such a big
deal after the garden do you think I'll
take a minute yeah who knows maybe the
uh maybe the Boston Garden will call me
right
the opportunities that the Garden opens
well you're you know that is how I think
yeah I'm going I'm going to take uh I
didn't take a break between the last
tour and this one the tour that ended
with the last special sorry I I had
shows to make up from the pandemic that
were that were scheduled in March and
June after the special came out
and I didn't have an act anymore because
I
had to dump all the material into this
you know the special right
everybody that comes to see me has
usually seen the most recent special
so uh and they expect new material
because that's what I've always done so
I had to write a new act very quickly
I didn't take I took maybe three weeks
off and I went right back to work you
went right back out there yeah and that
turn that turned out I did a different
process of writing an hour
uh how did it differ I just said I like
said you have to do this instead of
letting it flow I just made it happen is
it better to have the pressure
in this case it was because yeah it came
out good but then I had to it was next
thing I know I'm doing shows in Tel Aviv
and all the you know doing real concerts
with a brand new hour I usually like do
them but but it now it's bet this hour
is like really uh strong I think do you
feel fully back
yeah like fully back
yeah yeah good I mean back to what
nobody's ever back it's always forward
it's new that's a good point yeah okay
uh I don't have a thing about back and
my head I'm here you do in the garden
yes I am going back to the Garden that's
huge yes I'm really excited
I like that room it's you know in terms
of doing stand-up comedy is that a room
where you go this is the Pinnacle
uh no I mean to me honestly any great
show is the Pinnacle so like I I've done
the garden eight times and my life and
uh it was important enough to remember
that it was eight I don't know how many
times I've been to this it's amazing
Funny Bone I don't know how many times
but I can't say but
I've done the Columbus Funny Bone where
I've done shows where I'm looking out
the window of the plane the next day
going that was [ __ ] that was it that
was amazing that was it that's what I
would work for that's what I wanted yeah
that's what I this is what this that was
what this is all about that's why I give
a [ __ ] right so uh a show at the Garden
is definitely superficially like it's
you know the 19 000 people
um and it's Madison Square Garden and
Ali fought Fraser there yeah I saw you
know AC DC there when I was quite young
and yeah Led Zeppelin and I never saw
there but that's where they played
that's where there are concert film
takes place yeah that place touches a
lot of you know sure
uh
uh it feels like a pinnacle in terms of
it's that many people it's New York City
it's the premier room it's also
expensive it's expensive place renting
it is about 400 000. something like that
yeah I forget to just rent it of course
it's astronomical but they know they got
you because you want to play The Garden
you want to play The Garden I'm now the
new generation is like uh I guess the
Barkley is just as good
no but I mean in a gas but it is it's
just as many people and it's right
Brooklyn but it sounds like a better
city than Manhattan really not to me I
love right where I live I agree with you
but I'm talking about it for the young
people yeah that guy Brooklyn's the
thing what about the Bronx when does the
Bronx ever you know what I mean because
every area has been gentrified we've
gone into Jersey City or even Harlem
Harlem everything but there's something
about the Bronx that holds on it holds
on and it just goes we're never gonna be
anything but the Bronx it's gonna be
tough yes and that's what it is it's
still 1972 in the Bronx it's still long
Oldsmobiles yes on the street with
graffiti on them it's a Time Warp you
know like a guy in a leather jacket
carrying a briefcase yeah with the music
right
and somebody's gonna cut it I'm gonna
cut you man right I mean that's I never
go to the Bronx in four times in my life
yeah so we don't know what it's really
like right that's a good point some of
the Bronx is very beautiful you know
each wave Hill sure yeah the beautiful
areas yes there's Green in the Bronx
it's the Bronx to me is the most it's
the it's the best example of why a lot
of these urban planning things failed
when you look at these big buildings
that they build yeah where all of all of
the you know people have to live kind of
stacked on top of each other in these
very Bleak so but but when you say fail
yeah it depends on what the goal is
that's a great point so the urban
planning was just stick stick as many
people as possible into the cheapest
possible buildings right get paid by the
city subsidies right because it's not
just a simple building contract yeah
and make a [ __ ] ton of money and put
pack
all of those people into one small space
right out of Manhattan right
you know mission accomplished yes that
right so if that was the goal yeah well
done
it was yeah yeah no that's exactly right
but a lot a lot of great things hip-hop
came out of the Bronx like that that has
given us
sure good things yeah but unfortunately
at least they got hip-hop you know well
it's it I mean yeah that's it came out
of the Bronx it couldn't have come out
of Long Island where I lived it would
never have hip-hop would have never
emerged from Levittown Long Island we
just did but now it is I mean that's who
got rich from him that is exactly who
got rich no so even in that sense if you
packed a bunch of people way uptown in
these [ __ ] buildings right across
nothing yes also yeah their squalor will
create music that you will get rich from
that's right and then eventually they
will they'll get a little money but
which you can count on you will get the
Lion's Share because they'll die right
because it's gonna be bad yeah and
you're gonna take the money I'm sure
Biggie's mom gets a check but it's not
but it's not the check that she deserves
you know uh Josh Josh Josh Robin gets he
might get a bigger check he gets a far
bigger keep coming I just I bought a
Biggie album on iTunes recently yes
I like to listen to him when I'm jogging
yeah it's the best
uh but uh you know his mom he's not 14
cents yeah well those deals this keeps
on working this thing is keeps on
working yeah these 360 deals that
musicians sign yeah which is like a deal
where they give you an advance and then
they recoup the advance and it's
designed to keep you in debt it's
designed to keep you like constantly not
earning money it's designed to keep you
like beholden to the record company
that's right and everything they give
you they you think they're giving you
stuff right like they say hey guess what
fellas they go to the band they say
you're flying in a private plane and
they go yeah and then they pay for the
private plane that comes out of their
[ __ ] record yes and the private plane
is a deal that the company has uh you
know vertically yeah with somebody else
right all those bells and whistles are
just just horseshit yes yeah you have to
look after your your own thing I mean I
stopped taking advances on the road a
long time ago it's a stupid thing right
because it's a they get to call your
advance and expense and sort of take it
away from you and when they split right
well I had to give you an advance yeah
but where that's what right it's such an
easy con yeah that you really and nobody
will tell the artists ever right
nobody's gonna nobody sits down with you
and goes listen don't take that Porsche
yeah exactly right yeah or here's where
your Porsche is coming from they have
this thing now in the Bronx called drill
wrap yeah so what drill wrap is Eric
Adam just talked about it uh it's it's
very it's social media driven beefs with
young rappers under 21 young guys and
they diss each other on Instagram and I
mean literally they'll go outside of
someone's project and go I'm here like
with a gun they'd be like I'm right here
what if [ __ ] you yeah and and literally
it's they go on Instagram live so Eric
Adams is kind of like maybe we should
ban this on Instagram like the mayor of
New York's like why don't has it
resulted in any killings lots of
killings wow and the the music is is
reflective of no it's literally but the
kids are 16. so a guy a kid a 16 year
old was shot with a gun with a gun
because look I'm outside of the [ __ ]
whatever you know great black person
projects um outside of the whatever
whatever it is at Med Grabbers project
yes and uh come here and I'll kill you
so now everybody's like oh [ __ ] if I go
to his Instagram I can see this
everybody and then it starts having like
the little balloons
everybody is a little faces you see the
little faces yeah it starts really going
and people have been literally killed
then the guy shows up inside of the the
Instagram yeah I mean well he's doing
like I'm gonna go yeah kill my friend
yeah and it's and then has this resulted
in like this is resulted in live
Instagram deaths a few of them for real
for real I mean Bobby you can look this
up but it's resulted in deaths 100
and there and the the D.A is now trying
to use the rap lyrics yeah as as a way
to like convict because some of the rap
rap lyrics are so direct they're like we
killed him on 175th by the subway
yesterday right at 4 P.M so the D.A is
going like we're trying to put these rap
lyrics out as evidence right in addition
other things but it's a some of the rap
is very good I mean it's very like you
know it's very like it's got a whole new
sound and it's it comes to the UK has it
too this is going on in London where
it's like social media you think of all
the rap beefs that have happened of
people not liking each other now you add
social media everything happens in like
real time right but also it feels like
what's needed there
like when you look at a picture and you
go what's missing right and how do we
solve it with what we have today right
when you describe what those guys are
doing right what's needed is an app
yes that can bring them together more
easier right like a grinder for I'm
gonna kill you 100 like a social media
like a yeah like an app like and it's
like this and you go I don't want to
kill it like it but it's for killing you
like you're swiping well because it is
on some level a guy going I'm out here
he has a gun so I'm out here he's
wanting to connect with that person
that's right he's what I what he really
wants is to see him I think I'm not even
being facetious it's like no it's a need
to connect it's it's all that this
always is like when I was
um
I in my 20 like I don't know maybe 19. I
was just starting to do comedy
I had a really [ __ ] up job I was a
moderator on a phone line this is before
the internet people used to call party
lines I don't know if you use before you
remember I was 19 and you were dead I
was I was probably how old are you I'm
I'm 16. no I am I am 37.
yeah so that might have been before you
so a party line was calling up like a
party line like live girls type thing it
was all it was guys and girls okay it
was supposed to be come on the party
line we're all here hanging out oh on
the phone yeah on the phone it's a part
call up and you hear people
talking and so and then you get you can
switch to different rooms but it's rooms
of people like talking on a phone it's
like a chat room but it was just voices
wow it was a 900 number so you were
paying money
per minute to sit there and the the
point they started saying that it's
social but obviously the point is to try
to get laid right and
um the way what would happen is
uh because I so I got a job working
there and it's a being an operator
essentially and you have headphones and
a microphone and you have these Banks
and you see people light up you see oh
there's 10 people in this room right and
so you go to that room and it's 10 or
12.
uh guys and you go in in silence you see
that they're there
and there's silence because it's all
dudes
and then one light comes on and you hear
a girl go hello and you hello hello hey
hey they all try to talk to her because
no girls will ever want to call right
and my part of my job was to try to like
move people around so there'd be more of
a mix but mainly my job was to break up
fights and they disconnect guys who were
getting aggressive so they would because
mostly was just fighting yeah
hi who's that hey dude hey dude shut up
I'm trying to [ __ ] talk to her and
they would fight and then when they
would get in a fight this is in Boston
too all Boston Irish people trying to
get laid on the phone right minutes
dollars so when they got in fights
they'd go I'm gonna [ __ ] kick your
ass I'm gonna kick your ass and they'd
start yelling at each other and
threatening each other oh yeah where are
you I'll [ __ ] come right where you
are right now and and the guy would be
like I'm in Quincy [ __ ] [ __ ] homo
the other guy's like I'll [ __ ] I'm
I'm on door chest it's right right I'll
come to [ __ ] Quincy where exactly
[ __ ] Quincy are you I'm on [ __ ] uh
Third Street and whatever yeah wait a
minute is that near the the quick shop
he goes no what do you do and then
they'd calm down yeah to make plans yeah
what when are you gonna be there uh I
gotta I get out of work at seven and
they'd make a date yeah to fight to
fight to fight over a girl who's been
gone for 10 minutes yeah so it's kind of
a similar thing now now that you just
have social media and you're able to
broadcast all your activities so if you
want to go and show up outside
somebody's house yeah and say like where
are you [ __ ] you talked all this [ __ ]
on that record yeah where are you right
and it's becoming kind of I guess
for the mayor the mayor has said this is
a bear feels like it's got a
we got to put a stop to it yes well I
mean the other thing is there's a lot of
gangs and I always thought what's the I
always thought that what's the big deal
if it kid's in a gang and hear me out
because the way I feel about certain
things is that you know
is there are there no positives to a
gang this is we've we've we talk about
gangs like there's no positives to them
there's 100 percent positives to being
in a in a gang well to be just to parse
what you're saying you're not saying
that gangs are 100 positive no they're
saying that you're 100 certain yes that
there's one percent positivity well
there's gotta be well here's the deal if
you live in an area where being in it
it's almost required to be in again in
certain areas you go now obviously if
there's negatives to the gang life that
we don't even have to mention because
they're obvious they're seemingly
obvious you could be a rat you know and
that's not well right if you're a [ __ ]
if if you're you mean what could happen
to you if you're one of those things
well yeah if you if you can't handle it
like yeah it's obviously if you can't
handle the gang life it's bad there's
negative ramifications
but but and also every gang life ends in
death most likely well some prison and
which means another gang yes yes but my
whole thing is everybody always goes
gangs gang you know like my people like
where I grew up they're like that gangs
and I'm like what are we offering the
kids that isn't the gang that's my
question like well because here's what
happens right kids that end up in gangs
okay so like your mother
and I'm not describing every gang person
I'm describing somebody I'm making up
right
uh your mother is
you don't even know you haven't seen her
right
sometimes you see her on the street
right she's taking a guy into a uh
building foyer to suck his [ __ ] that's
right so that she can get some crack
cocaine right as soon as you see her go
oh that's I think that's my mom that's
mom's and you're with your friends and
you're embarrassed right and they tease
you they go haha your mom sucks a guy's
[ __ ] for crash she sucks but the way
they teased us yeah like you look funny
or you know like you you listen to Bay
City Rollers you know but they are like
your mom is sucking a guy's [ __ ] right
there for crap behind the McDonald's I
can see it and then you'll always have
that field one [ __ ] loser you'll
always have that one good friend who's
like don't worry about them yeah don't
worry don't worry about it their mom's
doing it it's not like their moms
nobody's that standing there to make fun
of that kid right has a great life
exactly so
probably they don't much tease each
other right because the guy the meanest
kids he's that guy's mom sucking a [ __ ]
and he goes I'm gonna let that go right
because I know how that's gonna come
back that's Mom yeah because that's my
aunt that's right that's Auntie yeah
so that's who that person's Mama start
there okay and he uh lives with his
grandma right
who is just hired at sucking dick so at
least there's that she's elderly yeah
and she goes to church and it's I mean
like it's like that's the church right
or whatever and I'm by the way this is
like 90s I don't know anything about
people's lives anymore I don't know
anything about anyone's life similar and
then his dad is uh killed his uncle and
his uh it was a double murderous
whatever and these people are in prison
and it's just and he goes to his school
um
where there's no there's just a cop
frisks you at the door yeah it's just
kids throwing chairs yeah it's true
there's no education yes yeah every day
he walks by these gangs and because he's
not affiliated right what the [ __ ] I'm
gonna kick your ass every time you walk
through this neighborhood that's right
and uh his friends all his friends like
if you just joined red you walk down red
streets and you're okay you're okay yes
that will you will be safe if you do
that and we have parties we have
barbecues right we go out we we we uh we
have fun we there's girl every girl you
want is Right Affiliated or in the gang
right and uh so then you join a gang and
you start acting tough and you start
talking about and then you start
carrying a weapon and then the city says
we gotta get rid of these gangs like
like if we get rid of the gangs right
the kid will be fine right like where
does he walk back like what do you okay
gang everybody go home to what right
home to what yeah so that's my that was
my whole thing it's like listen we all
know that gangs have a lot of negatives
and the problem is there's nothing being
offered to these kids
outside of that like outside of that
like we have not articulated a vision
for a lot of these young kids that
doesn't involve joining a gang right
that's the issue like we can be
horrified by gangs and people in the
suburbs are take a hike out I cannot
believe it well because it doesn't
become it doesn't exist for you until
they roll up your street that's right
until you try to go to their
neighborhood you go to their
neighborhood to buy crack right or to
get a [ __ ] from a crack [ __ ] right
and these gangs bother you absolutely
yeah so to me I was always like
obviously I'm not saying join a gang but
I've always understood that people in
certain areas they feel like it's the
best course of action for them
yeah sure and you know there's also
those people that do the the far
reaching ideas like yeah you know what's
a gang the Republican party
like no yeah you know what the real gang
is yeah the teachers union that's right
that's a real thing for you yeah well I
mean how do you it's hard to clean any
of that up how are you gonna how do you
fix any of that
it's tough no I know how to do it okay
but I don't it's boring to talk no of
course it's it's it's obvious but it's
boring yeah I'd rather do other things
yeah no I know it's you know what are
you gonna do so like you said you just
kind of watch
I think that there is a quotient is that
I don't even know what that word means I
use it too much no I think you're right
quotient yeah on a podcast know this
you're always right yeah until you have
any self-doubt right see what you're
experiencing right now is a very old
media thing where you go did I say the
wrong thing is that word wrong that's
old media it's yeah it's old media what
you have to adapt to now is that you're
creating reality every time you utter
something oh great okay yeah so you know
40 yes that's great there's a quotient
of uh human suffering that's just always
there so you can you can squeeze the the
the balloon here and it pops up here and
it's just I I mean the thing is as long
as you have a world where people want
more than they can hold in their hands
that's a problem there you're gonna have
this problem that's I mean it's so basic
it goes to the most basic thing that if
you don't get rid of it right you're not
going to solve anything right and should
you what the words the word solve and
goal and failure yeah are all relative
right to what you value and what you
don't you know right so if you like a
world where some people can be not only
rich but just like have four things
right that you don't know where they are
right if you own things that you're not
holding like this yeah you're part of
the problem right if you view those as
problems right the reason there are
gangs and murder is because I have some
stuff
that's behind the locked door and I
depend on a whole system to keep that's
right people from just going in there
but if you didn't need those if you
didn't need to have and I don't again I
don't mean I mean the wealthy obviously
is an acute example of it yeah
um
I don't know where human beings got this
urge to have more
than just a little thing of food and you
know what I mean a roof
a uh food you know a tool to make food
with you know
um but that's the stem that's where all
the problems all of them because if you
don't if you just need what you really
just need sustenance and a little
pleasure from right the sky and
the the nature then
um you need someone to look after [ __ ]
for you you need to convince someone
else that it's a good idea for them
to protect your stuff the stuff that
you're not you while you're sleeping or
stuff that you can't look at you know
what I mean and that creates that
creates a system of like people willing
to harm each other for somebody else's
money right
yeah and the only way you do that is by
convincing them something like well
they're from the other team or they're
the other religion or they're not really
bad people that kind of thing so yeah
but once you human skills are learned
for one thing and then apply to a bunch
of other ones so we learned this skill
of like a con get other people to
protect my stuff right for this and that
reason and get talk people into hurting
each other which isn't natural right
um
and then once you've done that you can
transfer that to many things like let's
make a whole country let's Annex the
country let's do this let's do that
let's do this let's do that and then you
you have people if you fast forward you
know have people in the Soviet Union or
not the I'm sorry Russia yeah breaking
their arms trying to avoid a
prescription a draft right and then the
government says well now you're a
one-armed Soldier [ __ ] dummy you
shouldn't have done that because now
you're gonna have an even a harder time
yeah you're out there that's right
because people in Russia now are going
hey we don't want to do this this is
your thing you know what's weird is
we're not in that war that's Russia
versus Ukraine right that's right we're
funding Ukraine we're obsessed with it
and we're not even in it we're not in it
but we're giving them money as far away
from us as you can get Awards we're
giving them money and we are giving them
weapons yes but you know that Iran yeah
like if you look on CNN.com yeah right
now
it's uh Trump
uh Trump trump yeah always
uh Marjorie green are you playing person
she's got four stories she's getting a
divorce Brett Favre use him they go
after Herschel Walker once in a while
like let's just bring up another hey we
just found out that Herschel Walker is I
didn't shave well this morning they just
that's what's on CNN.com and the weather
and whatever yeah I'm not saying the
weather about Tampa right
that's CNN.com right now I I ran is like
a central problem to American history
going back since I was alive yeah
they're having a [ __ ] Revolution
right now like they're having yeah
there's people there's Freedom Fighters
in Iran being like mowed down and
they're still they're just going [ __ ]
you we're gonna do this right and
they're fighting for a general sense of
Freedom against this regime that we've
been like saying is like they feed
weapons to the Russians they're evil the
evil Iranians who are and we conflate
them with it they're not even Arabs
they're not anything that anyone thinks
they are right
uh the the thing that the pro Iran's
problem with us was that we really
[ __ ] with them yes for years for years
so they got rid of our guys and they
just said all Iran is really ever said
the US is just leave us the [ __ ] alone
yeah get away from things
yeah but anyway yes so let's say they're
the biggest problem in the world there's
people there just like walking in the
streets with no weapons just trying to
get rights now like there's a huge
that's a huge you know that here really
cares no one gives a [ __ ] no one cares
it's not on CNN.com no it's not on the
whole if you scroll down you get to like
you know it's like here's a surprising
picture of Lindsay Wagner right the the
bionic woman right you know she looks
like [ __ ] now right I mean I've seen
it's on Instagram I was I once went on
politico.com yeah you have to take some
responsibility for the banner ad right
above your name right
that says Politico yeah and above it it
says the woman from
a Crocodile Dundee is disgusting now
that's what it said she's disgusting now
I was like wow okay Politico why don't I
get to believe the Politico they sold
that space and said hey if you want
Politico to sponsor your idea give us
money right and that idea was that girl
is disgusting now she's disgusting
disgusting that was the word used I
remember that very well but so that's
what's important to those people but
there's an actual thing I this I ran is
like a huge huge thing but it's on
Instagram like you go on Instagram and
you see that there's Persia because I'm
in L.A so in La everybody has relatives
in Iran so everybody is posting on
Instagram like please
talk about this yeah use your platform
amplify the voices but no one in no one
wants no one because they're not sure
what is that is that like yeah
terrorists what is Iran right and I
share the post of it like I shared a
post on my story I don't know what that
did but like you know there was a woman
that got killed there and I yeah I I
don't know the the morality police or
The Virtuous police whatever they are
yeah killed a woman right and then the
progressive people the woke people
killed her no the you know the the
Iranian guard they call it it's a
morality they have one there too they
have one there but it's different yeah
it's what ours wants to be right where
they actually that's why there's they're
going like hey don't right maybe that's
why they're not into it well the other
things attacking Iran because they
they're like we actually we want to do
that yeah well the other thing is just
like in in Putin's such a great villain
yeah he's just he's just a a Hollywood
Dylan yes a KGB yes kills his friends
white guy white man heterosexual white
man beautiful villain yeah and now the
Iranian mullahs are are less a trade
they have an old religion yes and
they're people of color and they've been
to and we'd [ __ ] and leveled in our
country and we overthrew and the Shah
the whole thing so there it's tougher to
kind of aren't the Kardashians
Kardashians they're Armenian I believe
Armenian there are Armenians so close to
the word Iranian yeah well they're
related they should care they sh they
should and they might do a post they
should be like okay we're not Iranian
but we're Armenian yeah it sounds like
it so please help please help well
there's also there's not much to do it's
the way I felt about Ukraine when it
happened was I was like hey well there's
nothing you can do about any of these
things it's not our [ __ ] business
it's not our business but if you're
gonna have a News website sure you
should mention a piece of news talk
about it but I mean an Iran Iran Iran
Iran yes
I've always been fascinated by it yeah
they make beautiful movies yes there is
a film there I I think it's called
cherry tree or sweet cherry or something
like that and it's about a guy I saw it
years ago on VHS
it's about a guy driving around town
asked he wants to kill himself but he'd
said his sin he can't do it so he's
driving around town asking people to
kill him
and it's just that it's like in real
time and it's just heartbreaking
beautiful beautiful movie right there's
another movie from there called the
separation that's actually was made in
international noise yeah like I still
makes films I think it's about an
Iranian couple breaking up
and raising their daughter separately
and it's in the trappings of their War
their culture and their Traditions but
it's really just
it's just a like there's a scene where
the dad is with his daughters like 14.
yeah and they stop to get gas and it's a
very beautifully shot movie you see the
guy and he tells his daughter
um the guy just pumped the gas and he
says pay the guy
and he gives her money and she goes how
do I she's never done that before and he
goes just go give him the money and get
the change and then you see him in the
mirror he's watching his daughter
negotiate a simple thing and he just has
this smile on his face yeah because he
knows he sees her doing something
growing up right that's such a moment
right when I saw that I was like
I didn't need that to tell me but it's
like there's no difference between me
and New York City you know right
divorced dad and an Iranian dad because
we're sold this idea that it's this
whole all of the world yes it's not a
beautiful culture right and uh
so they have I mean we there's we never
give a [ __ ] about the actual Freedom
Fighters like you don't really hear much
about the Hong Kong folks no
Taiwan it's like our goal is Taiwan John
Cena apologizes for saying that Taiwan
exists well no no our goals I don't
think it's ever been freedom I think
that's no no no no no no no we don't we
don't really want I don't even think we
want freedom here really no I think what
we want is this illusion of it and the
illusion that it is or the top of our
list like well you're saying we and
that's the thing is it's right amazing
thing about this version of like this
thing this this social media this not
this weird thing is that everyone
identifies with and says they use words
like everybody and we and we why is
everything like this it's not right
barely anything this is how I feel about
social media is that like everyone calls
it everybody
right like it's always like you know
John Travolta right said this and
everyone got mad that's always the story
first of all they're not everyone right
they're not even a lot of people right
they're not even most people they're not
even their whole selves right there's no
whole person right on Twitter none or
Instagram or uh or on in the media
because those are just giant twitters
those are just long tweets yeah
there's no whole person on Twitter it's
a fraction of a bunch of different
people that adds up
to a large number of fractions yes that
doesn't represent any whole person right
like if you cut a bunch of a dog's heads
off
and put them in a pile you wouldn't say
that adds up to like 50 dogs you
understand it's just their heads it's
just their heads and in this case it's
just their [ __ ] it's just their it's
just their [ __ ] period it's just this
yeah worst part of ourselves yeah of
them of not even all of I'm not on
Twitter most people aren't
almost nobody is on [ __ ] Twitter and
even the people that aren't aren't
actually holy there what's that's why
they wake up in the morning and look at
their own tweets and go yeah I love
doing this podcast I love talking to you
guys 14 years ago in 2008 I was a
mortgage security salesman can you
believe that that's not true I sold
retail mortgages but they don't know
that who wrote The Copy whatever reminds
me of what's going on now it's bad then
it's bad now one thing I really like is
Masterworks it basically it allows
people regular people to invest in art
invest shares in art you can't afford a
Picasso that's okay why do rich people
constantly put their money in art
because a lot of times uh it's beating
the S P 500 and they know it Microsoft
founder Paul Allen he has a billion
dollars worth of art he hoarded why he's
not an idiot he knew that [ __ ] was going
to appreciate proof is in the pudding to
date Masterworks it sold six paintings
for an average net return of 29 to
investors what Masterworks allows you to
do is buy shares in these iconic pieces
of art that only go up in value okay and
there is a wait list but they're look
they're hooking all my listeners up with
priority already access to their
platform just go to masterworks.art Tim
that's
masterworks.arttim for Priority Access
I'm telling you right now it's something
I wish I had done and I'm starting to do
now diversify money into the art world
because art continually goes up in value
okay rich people have done this forever
it's something that like Precious Metals
it just doesn't go anywhere so art you
love it you need it but you can't afford
it dummy so you got to get shares of it
this is true this is a fact
I'm being factual
Masterworks is the move just go to
masterworks.org Tim that's
masterwork.artslash gym for Priority
Access
see important regulation A disclosures
at masterworks.com CD that's
masterworks.com CD I love these guys
I love Masterworks I'm using it and it's
amazing I me and my friends and family
have used Masterworks now and it to me
it's something that I can't get enough
of I don't think you'll be able to get
enough of it
it's just one of those things it's like
oh here's a great thing I'm doing for
you again you know so many of my friends
are losing their hair and they're
they're switching to keeps keeps is so
great okay I'm telling you right now if
you want to keep the head the hair you
have on your head the way to do it is
keeps okay it is a hair loss treatment
prescription medication delivered at
home online doctor consultation it
doesn't cost a lot of money I'm telling
you everybody I know that uses it is
very happy about it they have convenient
virtual doctor consultations and
medications delivered straight to your
door every three months 24-hour care and
support low cost I'm telling you it is
everything your hair needs delivered
straight to your door with discreet
packaging proven results remember
prevention is key you don't want to
start trying to solve a problem once
it's already become unsolvable you want
to get it early I'm telling you right
now that's what keeps is so great when
it comes to your hair save more of your
hair and spend less clever slogan but
also true
if you're ready to take action
and prevent hair loss go to
k-e-e-p-s.com slash Jim Dillon receive
your first month of treatment for free
that's
k-e-e-p-s.com slash Tim Dillon to uh get
your first month of treatment for free
they're being incredibly generous and I
think that that is a really really good
thing uh for all the baldies out there
that are balding uh don't be a balding
baldy go to keeps save your hair what's
interesting is how
at this point in our society
going back
seems impossible meaning that the thing
that has been created seems to be the
thing that is going to be
either what drives us into Extinction uh
but it doesn't ever feel like people are
going to say wait a minute this on the
whole is overtly negative and that the
you know like everything about it like
every single thing about every single
thing about it is overtly negative and
yes there are positives just but but I
mean it's like I could I could show more
positives for being in a gang than
Twitter and it's not even close right so
it but it does feel like everybody's so
invested in it and it's taken over the
world so quickly that it's just you know
the people that are gonna opt out are
going to be you know just kind of like
they're going to be luddites they're
going to be people that are kind of Off
the Grid and they're not going to really
you know they're not going to be able to
participate in society because this you
know in order to participate now in any
societal function you have to be on the
ground so all if you're on the yes it's
true you can't even listen to a piece of
music you can't without a credit card
without a membership to the most elite
club of the American economy that's
right you can't when I was a kid a
credit card was a special thing yeah and
you paid for things with cash and checks
and you would sometimes have a credit
card but it was hard to get and you had
to sign up and be you had to have
accreditation yeah you have to be
approved you had to have your [ __ ]
together right that's still the case
right or or you have to be find an
entity that's willing to just like gouge
you for you know yeah for how much debt
you take on you know
um the debt that people have to go you
can't exist without debt no you can't go
like I don't like credit cards I just
wanna I wanna pay for what I have and I
don't want to have to be in debt you
must be and you have to create a open
debt
with a huge core frenzy that outweighs
you in every way right in order to
listen to some tunes in order to just
smoke a joint and listen to a song Yes
like that's and in order to get a job
now you have to have all these you know
profiles they search your social media
profiles that's right this is something
that you know in order to be uh uh you
know when you were apply to college they
search these things when you are so you
are recording all the mistakes you make
from when you're not telling kids you're
not telling them when they start this
stuff right that this is it this is
what's happening against you potentially
I mean that's look this is it's very
delicious yeah to describe how horrible
all this is right because you can go on
and on in so many directions right I do
think on some level it'll just go it'll
just sort of like become something else
interesting I have four nephews yeah
that are from like I mean my sisters
would be a guest at how little I know
know about these boys right their ages
but they're they exist I'm gonna say
they're between
um 14 to 21. okay
so they're like really the next people
yeah and uh they kind of get get it
right
they I have daughters too but I don't
want to talk about them that's personal
for my nephews I don't care right
but yeah or should you yeah they get uh
that that they have ways around [ __ ]
they hide in different places on the
internet well what's actually
encouraging to see is that kids now post
less so it's cringy to have a lot of
photos on Instagram it is like a little
my little cousin goes your Instagram's
cringe yeah because you have all of
these photos and I go that's my career
yeah because yeah but I have three
photos he goes so he goes I get it that
you're a comedian you have to do that
but I just have three photos like two
one of them's a night sky one of them's
like a skateboard and one of them's like
a blur a blurry face yeah that you can't
even tell is his but it is cool and
that's cool because if he was like
dressing grunge yes he goes if I post it
every day I would it would look thirsty
and oh I like hungry
so he goes I I stay away from that and
that's all people in his generation are
doing that hopefully that opens I mean I
think that's where it's headed it's like
we're like what is gonna happen because
mystery is cool again yes that's right
Mystique Mystique that's what ruined our
generation nation of of famous people
and artists yes there's no mistake
look right and it's so many images of
the same person right over and over and
over and over and over again I wanted to
ask you about the teacher and I want
Bobby to get this picture up there's a
teacher in Canada who's a trans teacher
the giantess yes it's like everybody's
the same [ __ ] stories everybody it's
the same story giant hits yes I mean
what is she doing in that class for well
no I mean
it's the same thing I think last week it
was the LA school system saying that
food is and your bid on it was
hysterically funny thank you but the
thing and I listened to your bit I just
laughed and laughed about let's tell
kids that all the foods are the same why
not the difference between the food sure
it was the best take on it oh thank you
but that thing which is just somebody
yeah who works at La unified po went
like this right and then plowing yes and
so then there was I listened to some
other podcasts that I actually like but
it was a very serious discussion do we
need this yeah and every go goes around
the bases and everybody takes a turn
well so now it's like who's got a taste
are so big yeah that's the thing it I
could ignore the story if they weren't
that big they're so massively big that
it this person wants you to discuss it
yeah but she doesn't need the whole
planet Earth to discuss it you don't get
tits that big if you don't think they
want everybody on Earth you want them to
be able to see the scene from space she
wants there's no way when getting these
tits they cheated but people have a
right to be [ __ ] stupid yes people
have this is the problem right now is
there's no local stupidity yes
localized stupidity yeah like there was
the the woman in somewhere else in
Canada
it all leaks out it's Global if you do
something stupid you are gonna [ __ ]
die from shame right because the entire
there's gonna be Joy read right and
eventually Putin right will say that
they
no one gets to just be like you know
this it's just the same as like [ __ ]
there's no coffee shop down the street
which is Starbucks it doesn't matter
where you are right so it's not like you
know what I like about you know or or
whatever [ __ ] Eugene Oregon is that
coffee place I used to go no it's right
you know what I like about Eugene Oregon
the same thing as the airport in
Cincinnati yeah it's just the Starbucks
yeah so no one gets to have a little
local culture with the you know there's
a weird person down there you know yeah
like that woman who was like the NAACP
chapter head who was white white yeah
Rachel dolezal yeah I'll see you know
her name she should have she should have
been able yeah I'm not chastising you
for noise you're the only you're the
only end user that's worthwhile for any
of this right right
but that woman should have been able to
be weird
I said let Alec bolden's wife pretend to
be Spanish I said let her pretend to be
black I think no sure yeah her name's
hilarious she's she's pretending to be a
rich Spanish lady she's not LARPing as a
maid she's not on all fours she's not
cleaning floors she's she's pretending
to be a rich better do you know the
difference between a rich Brazilian
woman and a rich Jewish woman not that
much difference so I was lit just let
her put on an accent she just wants to
have an affectation yeah she wants to
see you know she goes to these parties
these rich white [ __ ] every day she
wants to be a little different she wants
to stand out and her husband's Alec
[ __ ] Baldwin he just dominates all
the news so like just for her to be like
okay Justice for something for somebody
to go and where are you oh where are you
from and she goes uh you know it's just
something fun for her sure yeah but also
she wants to be International that's
right she married a man who's an
International Celebrity and yeah you
know gun guy so I mean and I so I've
always been I'm for letting everyone
pretend to be everything yes but you
then you have folks like uh the kids in
a in in Wisconsin
I think it was yeah who were taking a
class picture
and somebody said do a Nazi salute a
joke and they're just they're kids on
the planet Earth
in the middle of Wisconsin with a lot of
empty space around them yes and and they
they're living in a town that doesn't
benefit from a global Community right
just in a little place throwing a little
couch and they want to make a dumb they
want to make a dumb joke yes and they do
the Nazis so go ahead and like freeze
frame this
and meme I knew it he's a Nazi go ahead
right I can take it you can take it but
those young but those kids are just
wouldn't you know yeah I mean God the
[ __ ] you said when you're in junior high
school yeah and then somebody would
throw up and there it is throw up a
secret oh that we're doing it yeah now
we're [ __ ] let's give that another
all they they're all all everyone in
that picture was like thank God that
died down and now we're bringing it back
it's the nightmares of never-ending
nightmare
it's a NE I mean comedy is a terrible
part of this cycle well it's a terrible
part but these kids and then it's like
and then [ __ ] people from [ __ ]
assignment reason thought yeah going you
know or whoever the [ __ ] yeah they're
like it's like Auschwitz all over again
yeah it's just like the yeah this is
yeah I mean come on let them do a dumb
thing over there yes yeah well it's what
you you really hit on it brilliantly
with that term localized stupidity yeah
that doesn't exist and the idea that
people need to be stupid in their local
town and they need to have somebody go
hey you're an idiot and it doesn't need
to be national news and it doesn't need
to be in cultural moment or
international news no it just needs to
be something that's kind of quickly
forgotten right but what's not going to
stop any of that yeah is that there's
profit in it that's right do you ever
walk in your house and there's junk mail
on the floor like 10 cents
so now that's sent to a business manager
but yeah but it exists of course I still
get junk mail right with a little window
in the envelope with plastic in it yeah
then there's they put some in the window
that makes you that looks like a dollar
or something right
the idea I mean junk mail physical junk
mail work to take to to get in on the on
the scam yeah to be suckered yeah you
have to open it and fill it in and and
send it in and send it they might make
10 cents a month right
but it's worth it it's worth it it's
worth it it's a little more than they're
spending and so as long as that's and
then the internet there's no physical
you just go like damn [ __ ] you know
and the the trick with the media is just
to put a question mark yeah just like
this uh Scandal uh you know uh uh Robin
Williams was actually murdered by Sean
Penn right question well this gets you
out of the liability
yeah I don't know maybe yeah somewhere
in the somewhere in the story you bury
you do absolutely not it didn't happen
but people go huh as long as that'll
make 10 cents right they'll do it
there's always a profit motive that you
know yeah like going back to Iran for a
moment the last time I ran was the big
thing for us was in 1980 when the there
was the hostages right yeah uh the Shah
of Iran nobody remembers this these you
know you all think that you know Paul uh
Simon was in The Beatles so you're not
gonna know what I'm talking about right
but there was uh the shave Iran was a
puppet dictator that we was a direct
employee of the United States that's
right
and uh he was ejected by the Ayatollah
and by the Iranians who because he was
in he put incredible suffering on the
Iranian people just American
uh paid for suffering right I don't
remember what our why we made money
doing this yeah maybe they because they
had oil I don't know
but anyway when he so then there was
this thing with the Ayatollah and then
everyone was they were they took
hostages so we were expelling Iranians
out of the country we were throwing
submaranians out of the country and my
mom and my dad we lived in Massachusetts
then and my mom was at MIT learning
computers and she knew this guy who in
Cambridge he knew a bunch of that there
was he just was this guy who reminded me
of you a little bit that he's just a guy
who gets he's got his capitalism he's
right there you know what I mean right
so he figured out that there's Iranian
families all over Cambridge that are
needing to leave this week right
and they all bought their kids trans
amps they all bought their kids that
1978 black Trans Am with a gold eagle
that was Burt reynolds's car right in
Smokey and the bandits yeah and so he
knew that there was all these so he went
around to the houses of people like
frantically packing and said how much
for your Trans Am and he bought like 50
Trans Ams so we're brand new for nothing
put them all on a lot he bought a he
bought a a used car lot for like a week
and just moved them made a fortune yeah
so as long as people are making money on
that you're just not gonna stop it yeah
it wasn't a great analogy but that's
what that's why the woman with the big
tits yeah he's just paying off like a
slot machine and she's just being
drilled into it I mean either that or
maybe she's like maybe she's flourishing
maybe it feels good I don't know but I
but I have a feeling it's really not fun
for her and for the kids in her class
and for the teachers and the school and
all the local people see this is good
I never think about it like that yeah so
that's why I mean if you're gonna if you
go after you know [ __ ] uh share for
her the new lip or whatever the [ __ ]
it's a different thing I agree but
there's there's this I'm not even saying
you shouldn't do it no no because I
enjoy listening no I understand but
there's a certain thing now there is a
new social contract whether people like
it or not and I think there's a lot of
things to not like about it we've
Illustrated a thousand of them but there
is a new social contract where if you
get tits that are bigger than anything
that anyone has ever seen and you teach
in a school where you're in a shop class
you teach shop you solder things
together these tits you know my shop
teacher's name is Mr swanovsky he was a
creepy old guy and this is what every
shop teacher should be he was a creepy
old dude who never smiled and would just
make a face when we were doing something
because we were never doing the right
thing and he just cared about soldering
irons and heating them up and just
making sure that the little dumb rods
that you know and we put together these
little things that were and it meant
nothing and none of these skills mean
anything because you hire someone anyway
it's one of it's the least valuable
position in a school and you know that
because everything you do is fake nobody
in shop class goes you know what I want
to be an architect it never happens what
happens is like you just make little
[ __ ] things all day and and then
these kids just and you just try kids
the only thing in Shoppers don't hurt
yourself it's the only thing in child
class just don't kill yourself don't
hurt yourself please don't embarrass me
don't go to the nurse we don't want any
accidents in fact the first three days
of chop are him telling you about all
the horrible things that have happened
to other kids that didn't listen that
talk during the safety precaution this
guy burns his hand this guy can't use
his pinky everything's [ __ ] and it's
such a horrible job it's a bad job it's
not even like biology right where at
least you can go like they need to know
this it's nothing and then this woman
goes and says I'm gonna get the biggest
tip that anyone has ever seen not big
tits I'm talking about the cartoonist to
the point where it literally I have to
now stand back a foot and a half from
the saw yeah when I'm teaching the kids
because these kids now are in between
the kids and these shop [ __ ] things
and it's so cartoonish that she Waddles
around this room with the big big tits
and then she said and we should be
allowed to laugh at her because she's
done a ridiculous thing
she's done a ridiculous thing but I get
I get why a trans person would like shop
class because it's like we're building
things right everything can be built
yeah sure kids everything can be built
nothing's everything can be soldered
yeah and I get it I totally get it if I
was trans I would a class like that to
me I'd go this is good I'd want to teach
biology right I want to teach look what
we can build right but it's just when
you do it with such cartoonishly big
tits then the world should have at the
world should because you want it
you want it if so here's what here's
what okay here's what just happened that
I really enjoy yeah I'd like to just
observe sure
so the whole time that I was making the
point about localized stupidity yeah and
why do it the whole time and I remember
that remember the last few minutes this
yeah
it's like we were sitting in this car
that you're sitting there you're just
ready to go yeah and the engine is going
and I'm going like we don't need to do
this to people yeah it's too much it's
over over proportioned and you're going
uh-huh are you done okay and then you
went
you just went this and then you just did
well a big yeah bit about this lady
because she it it needs to happen yeah
in fact what I view comedy as is this
weird like
you know these dumb [ __ ] who walk
around houses in L.A with sage burning
yeah and they go I'm like getting rid of
the energy so the house will sell yeah
or whatever right oh yeah this is what
comedy is to me in in a weird way you we
need to kind of like there needs to be a
moment where everybody laughs at these
big tits yes and then we can all look I
can I could get with that on some level
you've got back-to-back meetings errands
to run shorts to take care of what's the
secret to clearing your to-do list folks
we know it it's doordash it is the
easiest thing in the world we've all had
experience with uh these carriers but
why is doordash the best I'll tell you
one of the reasons for a limited time
our listeners can get 25
more our listeners can get 25 offense
your delivery fees on their first order
of 15 or more when you download the
doordash app and enter code Tim Dylan
download the doordash app enter code Tim
Dillon that's 25 percent off up to ten
dollar value and zero delivery fees on
your first order when you download the
doordash app in the app store and enter
the code Tim Dylan you can get stuff
from your favorite restaurants you can
get groceries I mean you can get last
minute school supplies doordash covers
you it's got you covered schools back in
session the kids are nuts you're trying
to figure out how to deal with it your
husband or wife is starting problems of
jobs unfulfilling you're basically
trying to just keep a lid on things the
last thing you need is a problem at
dinner oh they need folders for school
doordash don't want to run out traffic's
not doordash oh I want dumplings
doordash I need some groceries doordash
you use my code you save money with over
300 000 Partners you can support your
neighborhood go-to's
or choose your favorite National
restaurants like Popeyes Chipotle or the
Cheesecake Factory again I'm going to
tell you again don't forget go to the
App Store download the doordash app
that's code Tim Dillon Tim d-i-l-l-o-n
for 25 off your first order with
doordash subject to change and terms
apply
I use doordash and I have for a very
long time and it's always great and I'm
really excited to bring this partnership
to the people
the NFL action is in full swing here at
DraftKings Sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of the NFL we're talking
touchdowns big plays and even bigger
wins new customers can bet just five
dollars on any NFL team to win and get
200 in free bets if they did 200 in free
bets if that's not enough everyone can
boost their winnings with DraftKings
stepped up same day game parlays right
now for every leg you add you get to
boost your winnings up to 100 with
payouts bigger than ever why bet on
football anywhere else to make things
even sweeter you could throw down on
stepped up same game parlays once per
game day all season long
listen download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app now and use promo code
Tim Dillon to get 200 in free bets if
your team wins when you place a five
dollar bet on any football game that's
code Tim Dillon
t-i-m-d-i-l-l-o-n only at draftking
Sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the NFL this is a great place
to bet it's a lot of fun I mean I'm
telling you right now you're boosting
your winnings up to a hundred percent
five dollars on any NFL team and get 200
in free bets that can also result of
course in more money so I'm telling you
right now call to action
um okay we'll edit that out but uh
telling you guys one more time it's easy
just download the DraftKings Sportsbook
app now promo code Tim Dillon get 200 in
free bets
um draftking Sportsbook and official
sports betting partner of the NFL
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
imply I use DraftKings and all my
friends do and absolutely everybody
loves it if you were somebody you know
as a gambling problem crisis counseling
and referral services can be accessed by
calling 1-800 Gambler that's
1-800-800-426-2537-1800 gambler
I mean what happens Bobby show the
goddamn tits because without the tits
It's academic
this woman did not get those tits to be
ignored she did not get those
no but she's got okay put it away
she has a body dysmorphia yeah but
she didn't want to be on the Tim Dylan
show oh I don't know about
that she didn't want to be on the Tim
Dylan I don't know about that man those
did there you can't you get those to be
ignored
not but yeah by the you it's not the
point the point is you got something
tells you that that's what you need I
don't know but it's a very internal
thing
external thing yeah well it manifests
external yeah it's a very external thing
too I mean I get what you mean and I'm
not I'm not saying she shouldn't be no
listen here's the problem is that once
things float up right to the comedy yeah
I get it and I have again my issue is
not with you no of course it really
isn't well of course
of course but by yourself
no of course of course no it couldn't be
me
um
I mean what I believe about comedy is
that there is no moral arrow in comedy
there's no moral up or down there's no
moral gravity and comedy that's what we
do and yes I do think that on some level
it's like
you're saging out all those serious [ __ ]
that got said about her yes and the
people I'm sure got really angry on both
sides well both sides the left and the
right tits any of the sides yeah and
either tit either one but uh I had I'd
just like to tell you a story about Sage
because I was once home and this woman I
get a knock on my door yeah and it's a
woman says hey I'm from next door the
house next door had sold recently right
she said I'm from next door and I was
wondering if I could borrow a pot
and a wooden spoon if you have that and
I said I do I said it's so nice to have
you in the neighborhood right when like
uh like looks weird right I said do you
need anything else
salt or paprika or something you know
and she said no just pot in a spoon
and that gave them to her and then she
came back about two hours later and said
and gave them back to me
thank you and she was little
standoffish and she left
and then about a month later I get it I
see them all moved in I get a knock on
the door a different woman she says hey
I'm your next door neighbor I just want
to say hi I said you guys came here to
get a pot and a spoon she said oh that
was a woman I hired to get evil spirits
out of the house right so she took a pot
from me and used the spoon to get evil
spirits into the pot and then gave it to
me I love belief systems because I love
the idea just think of that evil spirit
just a coupling of words evil spirit
will just go oh I don't like that herb
like I'm out like if you're an evil
spirit Sage will do it that to me has
always been shocking like what people
believe
that's interesting yeah like if you're
an evil spirit and you're trapped in
this house yeah they're just some things
and you go I I can't I know I mean I
know I'm an evil spirit who's trapped
here because I was murdered in the
basement yes but if you if you light
Sage on fire I'm out of here it's just a
thing it's for your mind I think yeah
just to see you feel better about it
before we get out of here there's an
article about people the overpopulation
is going to be concerned um going to be
fixed by metaverse children
this is a thing where people are going
to have children in the metaverse
because they're not actually there
they're not real and I and I wanted to
get get your I think anybody who
believes that yeah should absolutely
have a metaverse child instead of a
physical child that's right I think that
we should end
the DNA strand that believes that yes I
mean those there's those people that you
know there's that thing
where they're all trying to get in the
Mainframe yes and live forever yeah
please do please do please all of you
yeah please upload yourselves yeah
they've already started it with meta is
a place that they're creating right so
they can go to it and live forever right
and by the way when you get canceled now
yeah you just you can live in your home
and feel okay right but in meta it's
going to be
Purgatory it's going to be they'll
actually send you to hell what's
interesting is you could go to a
metaverse they're going to make a hell
of it the idea of that of course they
are damning you well that every day
because when you're once you're in
metaverse once that really becomes
existence right you're gonna have to
defend yourself there you're gonna
that's a great Point earn every day that
you belong that's a great Point all of
this mechanism of looking into
everything you've said and thought right
is going to be used to weigh where you
belong in the metaverse do you think
that they're really going to create a
metaverse without a hierarchy without a
system of you I don't know right and
what happens to you in that matter well
you get a lot you they put they have a
room for the folks there's not going to
be a metaverse without Justice no of
course not so then
that's what all of this is practice for
interesting all of this stuff that we're
that they are doing now right small
parts of people right they're they're
and maybe it's a sage-like thing they're
getting it all into the thing into the
Mainframe and we can let all that go how
beautiful that would that be and then
we're just left with people walking in
the streets don't we are actually using
their whole Personality yeah
because the the thing about
click bait cancel all this tweeting is
that it finds sectors of your person
right right I was talking about this on
another thing once that when you watch a
movie with your whole self you take your
entire body to a movie and you put your
phone down and you sit there and you
watch a film or a comedian or whatever
your whole self takes in the movie right
right your whole self isn't gonna like
it there's parts of you that are going
to feel good
there's Parts either going to feel angry
there's Parts you are gonna you're gonna
have a mixed reaction because you're
using your entire multi-faceted human
Spirit right
and that's going to create conflict in
you I don't know how I feel about that
movie you talk to your friend about it
afterwards you go I don't like that he
did that at the end you know what I mean
uh but I liked it I don't know that's a
rich experience right but it's very rare
and for filmmakers and for Studios it's
hard to know what thing is going to end
up with an aggregate positive you know
what I mean right but if you tickle one
part of somebody you know this is what
you think right and wrong is this is
what gets you off sexually this these
little parts of you that's a direct
[ __ ] touch that's like yes it's like
a drug right and you react to it and
it'll just keep getting more and more
and more and you'll just keep wanting
that more and more and more so that's
the the anger towards other people all
these things they hate and and and uh uh
viral this and that it's just touching
little parts of each person and you
don't have to appeal to them that's why
everything's fragmented why no news
shows the big picture right and no news
story is really about here's what's
happening in Iran that's a big big story
big story of wide ranging for a long
time now this might There's an
opportunity in Iran for them to be like
a a a a cultured and complex nation that
we might actually be friends with right
and why isn't you know like I saw Joe
Biden say
um
uh American Arms are flowing into the
Ukraine as I speak I saw him say that
proudly and I was like
flowing flowing as I speak he said that
in Belgium when I was in I was in Europe
and you know if there's a shooting war
and you send and you flow arms into it
more people get killed that's right more
people die yeah so and I know that the
young Progressive kids that have like
the little Ukrainian flag on their on
their uh ID are very comfortable with
dead Russian soldiers right with like
charred face yeah they don't care loaded
body yeah like like coming out of a tank
right like you know you you know it's
right go us you know whatever fine but
uh but some effort to not just say out
loud somebody Biden anybody yeah I wish
them well I hope you know at least do
what Trump used to do for people I wish
them luck I love it I wish them well the
Iranian folks that are putting their I
wish some luck yeah and I don't I don't
know anything about it you know it's not
our job no it's not our job it's our job
to [ __ ] on all of it and make fun of it
and also just as Americans too it's like
we can sit it out
we have a disease in this country where
you can't that's Ralph he owns the
studio I don't care because you were
here he came what he does is he came and
took a photo of this and he's gonna go
back and you see you see why I know and
because his account's gonna he's been
losing money for three years he's gonna
go and slowly CK the account's gonna go
wow I'm telling you right now we're in
the we're gonna die here you know a
picture of me is not a good proof of
concept I I beg to differ I beg that
there it is in this world if you're like
me and you're embarrassed that you don't
know more than one language you got to
get on Babel Babel is the language
learning app okay that has more than 10
million subscriptions thanks to Babel's
addictively fun and easy
bite-sized language lessons you can
finally cross learning that new language
off your list with Babel you only need
10 minutes to complete a lesson so you
can start having real life conversations
in a new language in as little as three
weeks I've always wanted to learn uh
other languages I'm kind of embarrassed
I don't know them to be honest with you
but I'm using Babel to get over my
insecurity other language learning apps
use AI for their lesson plans but Baba
lessons were created by over 150
language experts and voiced by real
native speakers not computers with Babel
you can choose from 14 different
languages including Spanish French
Italian and German plus Babel speech
recognition technology helps you improve
your pronunciation and accent there are
so many ways to learn with Babel in
addition to lessons you can access
podcast games and video stories and even
live classes plus it comes with a 20-day
money-back guarantee start your new
language learning Journey today with
Babel right now get up to 55 off your
subscription when you go to babel.com
Tim that's babel.com Tim you can get 55
off your subscription to Babel I'm using
it right now to learn Spanish me guste
elado and that is very very good
babel.com Tim for up to 55 off your
subscription Babble language for life
um but no I I everybody should go see
you at your last show yes at Madison
Square Garden also I'm in Wembley Arena
Christ I'm at Wembley and this one I
need to sell tickets to they're not
buying that many tickets sell them in
you goth-free Wembley Arena yes in
London October 4th this coming [ __ ]
Tuesday that's amazing and uh uh the
night before I'm at the Hammersmith
Apollo that's sold out that's been sold
out for amazing Wembley there's still I
think 6 000 tickets available for
Wembley if you are one of six thousand
people in the UK you gotta go to the
store go to this show in Wembley what
are you doing I'm going to do something
shocking at that time he's going to do
something I'm trying to do something I'm
I don't want to Telegraph it of course
but I might commit suicide at that show
Wembley still buy tickets to the Garden
think about the ad rev that you will get
on a picture of Louis CK committing
suicide yes think about that because we
restricted we restrict the phones yes I
mean we don't put them in the specs
anymore I don't do that anymore okay I
just we tell them don't take it out but
during this
what I'm saying is that if you get a
picture yeah
you'll be one of the few because we are
stopping people so that'd be worth a lot
of money it's worth a lot of money
please come to Wembley Arena also I'm
coming to Milwaukee I'm coming to
Atlanta uh New Orleans I'm thinking of
places that haven't sold out yet uh
Nashville I'm playing the Grand Ole Opry
in Nashville no October November
December 14th and I'm in Pittsburgh at a
place coming to Pittsburgh and uh uh all
those [ __ ] all those [ __ ] places
and you can go on my website buy all
seven specials for five twenty five
dollars it's the best deal uh you can
buy my new movie Fourth of July yeah and
uh the series Louie that I made the best
it's not on anywhere but my website so
it's exclusive I got it exclusive they
took it off of Amazon and off of apple
and they gave it to me exclusively right
and the reason I asked him to do that
was so that I could set a price that
those people wouldn't have because you
have to always be the same price yes to
have like competitive parody whatever
right so you only paid 30 bucks you you
get all five seasons and you can stream
them for the next five years so that and
Bobby Kelly made a special that I
directed I saw right now it's the best I
saw it you're lying and I appreciate it
no no I saw it he went into the bar okay
in in in [ __ ] Round Rock Texas
destroyed right and he destroyed yes and
it's amazing it's called kill bucks yes
and uh we just gathered people in this
box this old [ __ ] Factory in Tampa
yeah and he went in there and he just
crushed yeah and so it's on my website
October 8th yeah uh for I think 10 bucks
and Bobby's coming on the show too he's
gonna be out good and I like my [ __ ] and
thank you by the way you're a big
supporter of this show people don't know
that but you're you you how do I support
it without people knowing though well
you just tell me that you think things
are funny yeah which to me is how you
should support it makes me happy I
listen to your show like I listen to it
like a regular person when I make my
breakfast well that makes me happy that
you think things are funny so that's how
you say supported in front of you with
uh the woman in Chicago what's her name
the Lori Lightfoot The Lori Lightfoot
Tim Dylan yeah just Google Lori
Lightfoot Tim villain it's one of the
best pieces of audio Yeah I appreciate
it she's a um and you guys found that
too right wasn't that your guys finds
yeah for Yelp that she reviewed a
limousine company other people knew
about it and then the through the you
could tell through the the the limousine
companies replied that they it was all
lies and someone found but son your
organization someone found that we found
it and your dissection of it yeah I
listened to it on on a tour bus yeah
it's one of the funniest things ever
it's a great piece that's great
of journalists we try and uh you know
Lori is or the gift listen if I lived in
Chicago I'd probably be angry but I
don't so it's pure comedy I wanted to
win again yes I wanted a win-win-win
because there's some cheese there's
nothing better than a petty yeah kind of
small even though Chicago is not a small
town but like a small town petulant
childlike dictator which is the way
she's incredible it's an incredibly
nothing is better than like a mean
lesbian who like gets infused with local
businesses nothing better than that
that's nothing local stupidity that's
local great level localized yes if if I
lived in Chicago I bet most I bet
Chicago local papers make way more money
on her because in the morning they have
the crazy her with the eye yeah and it
says like guess what she did today and
people were like [ __ ] every [ __ ]
like it's like uh the Metro it's like
the T in the 40s when they show
everybody with the newspaper no it's
it's absolutely what is it she do now
what is she doing it is wonderful that
America we have these characters we have
these characters nobody has better
characters no we are an amazing story
there's no way that you can create a
cast of characters the way this country
has incredible Trump and Kardashians all
of these things and Lori Lightfoot it's
it's such a and you know and as when
again Winston wafts up to you yeah what
you do with it you should never hold
back no you shouldn't you I don't know
how yeah you there's no that's once it
gets to you it's too late that's right I
believe that that's right it is once
it's here yeah it's too late too late
it's time to go hard yeah for sure
[ __ ] dig in baby it's beautiful I
love what you do very good Louis CK go
get everything he has why should I come
go to my website otherwise I can't do
this anymore
except my own industry now at Louis
ck.com buy all the [ __ ] give go give
them the money now yeah thank you all
right thank you sure man I appreciate it
it was fun